grab your speeders and Bhaskar
yes it's episode 5 of the Mandalorian
and yes my intros get worse every week
here's a picture of baby Yoda to make it
up to you we have another awesome
episode of the Mandalorian and together
we're gonna break it all down analyzing
its clues and Easter eggs just not that
one you'll want to stick around till the
end since I'll be going over that
mystery character and a crazy clue that
pretty much proves who that figure is so
let's jump to it episode 5 wastes no
time getting right into the action with
our first space chase the Mandalorians
razor crest is under attack by a rival
bounty hunter remember we left off
episode 4 with mando having to take the
child off planets organ knowing that no
matter where he goes he won't be safe
that planet would have been perfect for
him to grow up on but these tracking
Bob's ensure that they'll be constantly
on the run the bounty hunter says the
line I reckon began cold which is the
same line the mandalorian used in
Episode one and it's the Mandalorian who
pulls some Top Gun moves slamming the
brakes allowing him to blow the crap out
of his assailant but the attack isn't
without its losses the razor crest has
blown an engine and needs to emergency
land on a planet where you'll never find
a more wretched hive of scum and
villainy yes
Tatooine specifically the city of moss
eisely I don't like sand we can see here
two of tattooing three moons not to be
confused with its two binary Suns the
razor crest lands in one of Moss Isley's
hangar bays and here is baby Yoda
sleeping here we meet a character named
Pelle mano played by comedian Amy
Sedaris this is the first time we've
seen her character in the Star Wars
universe who is a mechanic and part-time
babysitter we also get to see these pit
droids which made an appearance in
episode 1 The Phantom Menace or you may
remember them from the wildly popular
video game Star Wars pit droids these
droids were mass-produced on sir Ilya
and gained popularity and hangar Bay's
across the galaxy during the Galactic
Republic due to their ability to carry
weight far greater than their own
still the mando doesn't want the
Lloyd's working on his ship we've seen
him have a disdain for droids back in
Episode one when he specifically asked
for a human operated ship rather than a
droid one my guess as to why he hates
droids well they killed his parents back
in those flashbacks we saw Pelle uses a
device to analyze the extent of the
damage on the razor crest it's gonna be
quite the job considering the
Mandalorian won't let her use the droids
he only has 500 Imperial credits and we
know since the Empire has faded away the
value of imperial credits has
significantly dropped and that 500 will
only cover the cost of the hangar he
tells her he's good for it and we see
this payoff for her later on in the
episode as we venture deeper into moss
eisely we have these stormtrooper
helmets on spikes Tatooine was never a
planet that had much love for imperial
rule in Return of the Jedi we see
citizens of moss eisely celebrating the
fall of the empire back at the hangar
Pelle is playing a game of sabacc with
the droids you may remember SABIC as the
game young Han Solo played against Lando
Calrissian to win the Millennium Falcon
this game however seems a bit lower in
stakes betting small parts which we can
see on the table their game is
interrupted when a loud noise emanates
from the ship it's just a child who
Pelle picks up and we'll let her charge
mando extra for babysitting one of the
interesting things about moss eisely in
the Mandalorian is that it's far less
populated it seems as though Tatooine
has fallen on hard times like much of
the galaxy even the cantina which was
filled in a new hope has only a
spattering of patrons this could
possibly be because the droid who runs
the place tells mando that the bounty
guild no longer operates on Tatooine
which is probably good for our hero
since he's on the run from them
enter Toro Cala can a bounty hunter
wanna be wanting to make a name for
himself with a guild fun fact he's
played by Jack Cannavale a the son of
Bobby Cannavale II who you may have seen
recently in the Irishman he's holding an
imperial coin
sitting in the exact spot where Han Solo
killed Greedo which really tells us all
we need to know about this character
he's only in it for himself and is not
to be trusted
he's got a bounty puck for an elite
mercenary known as fennec Shan at first
the Mandalorian wishes him luck fennec
is known among the top crime syndicates
as a
Liss Merc geez even worked against the
huts which takes some balls
but when Toro says the mandalorian can
keep the earnings and that Toral's just
in it to gain clout with the guild the
mandalorian is in he's strapped for cash
and could use the job
Toro tells him that since the New
Republic has taken control they put a
lockdown on all of Phoenix employers now
she lives on the run his tracking fob
indicates that she's beyond the Dune see
the Dune see also being the location of
Jabba's palace and obi-wan Kenobi's home
fun fact according to Java legend the
dune see used to be a vast ocean Toro
smashes the fob indicating his distrust
of the Mandalorian if the Mandalorian is
gonna find fennec he'll need Toro mando
heads back to the ship and has a mini
heart attack when he can't find the
child before Pelle appears holding him
you've an awful lot to learn about
raising a young one and that sentence is
really what this show is all about the
Mandalorian learning to grow as a
character through his relationship with
this orphan child while the Mandalorian
might be about cool action scenes and
space battles at its core it's about
this relationship the Mandalorian and
Toro take off in speeders but it's also
important here that Toro sees the child
if he had never seen this child he never
would have believed fennec when she told
him that the Mandalorian was wanted by
the bounty hunters guild wanted so much
so in fact that his head would give him
even more clout than hers in the dune
see they stopped to deal with the
Tuscans they almost magically appear
behind Toro like they did to Luke in a
new hope thankfully the mando knows how
to communicate with them Trading Toros
binoculars for safe passage beyond the
dunes they stop yet again when they come
across a lone do back with a dead bounty
hunter attached it's likely this guy was
also searching for fennec judging by his
tracking fob and was also shot down by
her the investigation is short-lived as
mando is shot by an MK sniper rifle a
shot he probably wouldn't have survived
if it weren't for his best car steal the
Mandalorian is able to get to safety and
he suggests they wait till night to
stand a better chance of getting a
fennec the problem is she has the high
ground his plan involves using flash
charges to briefly stun Finnick giving
them enough time to reach the ridge
without getting shot the Mandalorian is
hit yet again and flies into the sand
man he is not having a good day
but before fennec can get a lethal shot
she's held at gunpoint by Toro they have
a brief battle fennec being the more
experienced fighter but the Mandalorian
intervenes and they are able to cuff her
she asks if he's the Mandalorian that
caused the big uproar on Navarro this is
the first time we're given the name of
that volcanic planet we saw in episodes
1 & 3 where the Mandalorian fought off
the bounty hunters guild apparently word
has spread of his exploits with only one
working speeder the Mandalorian offers
to go back in search of the Dewback
leaving Toro with fennec then accuses
this opportunity to sway Toro if its
entry into the guild he wants what
better capture than the Mandalorian
getting him would make him legendary
heck his armor alone is worth more than
her bounty and he would be welcomed into
the guild with open arms you want to be
a bounty hunter
make the best deal for yourself and
survive this is interesting advice from
fennec considering it's the opposite to
what the Mandalorian has done so far on
the show the Mandalorian could have left
Navarro with his prize money after
dropping off the child but he didn't he
basically took the option that was
simultaneously the worst deal for him
and that had the least chance of him
surviving and when it looks like Toros
going to team up with her he shoots her
now I should have seen this coming but
this actually surprised me since Vinick
has been built up online almost as
though she was set to become a recurring
character but I'll get into a little bit
more about fennekin a bit
mando makes it back to Mos Eisley it
probably took him forever on the back of
that do back and sees Toro speeder near
the entrance to the hangar as the
Mandalorian makes his way in
Toro emerges holding Pelle and the child
as hostage dropping his blaster to the
ground the Mandalorian is cuffed by
Pelle but is able to use his flash
charge to create a distraction and gain
the upper hand on Toro
thankfully the child is unharmed thank
God and the Mandalorian is able to pay
Pelle from the leftover credits found on
Toros corpse and judging by her reaction
it's a pretty sizable sum Pelle tells
the droids to dispose of the body in
beggars Canyon beggars Canyon is
mentioned in a new hope during the
battle of the Death Star Luke used to
play there as a kid with
BIG's just like beggars Canyon back ha I
just hope there weren't as many dead
bodies back then the Razr crest takes
off into space ready to begin its next
adventure
but perhaps the most cryptic scene is
this cliffhanger a figure walks towards
the seemingly dead body of fennec now
the prevailing theory out there is that
this is boba fett the famed bounty
hunter who supposedly died in the
Sarlacc pit on Tatooine roughly five
years ago the evidence here fully
supports this both wear capes dressed in
similar colors although it's a bit tough
to make out in the dark and he carries a
blaster but perhaps the most interesting
evidence is this listen carefully as
Boba Fett enters this scene in Empire
Strikes Back now listen to the sound
here in the Mandalorian
[Music]
it's the same exact sound effect now
maybe that could be a coincidence II
might be an entirely new bounty hunter
we haven't met yet
or perhaps Moff gideon but my guess is
that guy wouldn't be out alone in the
desert he'd probably be surrounded by
troops now is fennec dead well I'd say
her character was a distraction for the
bigger Boba Fett reveal but if cloning
is part of this series as dr. Pershing
alluded to earlier on in the season who
knows what could be possible finally
where could we be going next
well according to IMDB Episode six
centers around the Mandalorian joining a
crew of mercenaries on a dangerous
mission now this is likely where we'll
meet bill burrs character and this
Twi'lek you can see the Razr crest at
docked in what appears to be space so
this may be a matter of if he helps them
they'll let him go kind of thing that's
it for this video I hope you'll give it
a like and subscribe I also want to hear
your thoughts and theories about the
show below do you also think it's Boba
Fett you can also follow me on twitter
at think story whitey and until next
time remember I have spoken